في بعض الأحيان ، تكون اللعبة الجميلة
مجرد لعبة
، ثم هناك أيام يكون فيها الأمر
أكثر من ذلك بكثير بالنسبة لهؤلاء المشجعين السعوديين
اليوم ، كانت إحدى تلك الأيام التي
أذهلت فيها الصقور الأرجنتين كأحد
المرشحين المفضلين في البطولة 2-1 في
واحدة من أعظمها.  مفاجآت في
تاريخ كأس العالم ، كيف تشعر بأنني
مدهش تمامًا ، لقد كانت مباراة جميلة
قمنا ببنائها مع ميسي الأرجنتين في
الواقع واحدة من المرشحين للفوز
بالمباراة التي لم يهزموا فيها في المباراة رقم 36 ولكن
احزروا من
هزمهم [تصفيق]
ولكن هذه المباراة تذهب  أعمق بكثير من
مجرد نتيجة فوز ديفيد على جالوت ،
إنها صورة أمير قطر وهو
يرتدي وشاحًا سعوديًا وهي حقًا
رمزية للغاية ولهذا السبب حتى العام الماضي
، كان كازا والسعودية قد تعثرتا في وقت كبير
في عام 2017 ، قطعت الرياض الدبلوماسية والسعودية.
العلاقات التجارية إلى جانب ثلاث دول عربية أخرى
تتهم الدوحة بدعم
الجماعات المتطرفة ، والتي
لا يزال كاتا ينفي
أن الضغط الاقتصادي كلف قطر
مليارات الدولارات خلال تلك
السنوات الأربع.  أخبرتني مصادر بصعقة الأذن هنا على
انفراد أنهم يعتقدون أنها كانت خطوة ولدت
من الغيرة الخالصة لأن الدوحة قد
فازت بحق استضافة أكبر حفل رياضي في العالم ،
وهي المنافسة التي
أصر كارتر دائمًا على أنها مخصصة للجميع
منذ اليوم الأول قلنا أن هذا هو
بطولة للمنطقة وما زالت
مستمرة في كونها بطولة
للمنطقة ، عملنا دائمًا وسعى جاهدين
لضمان أن
تمتد فائدة كأس العالم إلى ما وراء قطر
لشعوب المنطقة ، ثم في يناير
2021 ، كانت الرباعية كما كانت معروفة.
فجأة تراجعوا عن قرارهم
وعاد كارتر إلى دليل على
ذلك التوبيخ هنا خلال
حفل الافتتاح مامي بن سلمان من
المملكة العربية السعودية مرتدية وشاح كاتري
إلى جانب أمير قطر مما
يعيدنا إلى هذه الصورة يوم الثلاثاء
لتيمي مالثاني في المباراة السعودية.  مرة أخرى ضد
الأرجنتين
فوزًا كبيرًا لكلا البلدين
على أرض كاتري داخل وخارج الملعب
ولحظة من الفرح الخالص للجماهير العربية
من جميع أنحاء المنطقة.  بيكي أندرسون
سي إن إن الدوحة